aspergé de gaz lacrymogène visée par des
tirs d'armes automatiques ces habitants
de Carson se mettent à fuir ils étaient
venus dénoncer l'invasion russe en
Ukraine ici la population tente de faire
face à l'armée russe qui a pris le
contrôle de la ville la seule prise
importante depuis le début des combats
car autre personne les forces russes
semblent avoir de plus en plus de
malades en C c'est en tout cas le
ressenti du Pentagone
nous avons vu des signes que les
Ukrainiens passent un peu plus à
l'offensive à présent going ils se sont
défendus de manière très habillée très
agile très ingénieuse dans des zones qui
considéraient comme des zones à défendre
pour beaucoup Moscou envisagite une
guerre éclair avec notamment la prise de
Kiev en quelques jours mais près d'un
mois après le début des combats la
capital ukrainienne résiste toujours
avec même des tentatives de
contre-offensive autour de la ville
dans le sud l'armée russe vise depuis le
début de port stratégiques d'abord Mario
Paul avec son accès sur la mer d'Azov si
la ville subit des bombardements
constants elle n'est toujours pas tombée
aux mains des forces russes autre point
stratégique au dessin qui donne sur la
mer Noire mais pour leur les forces
russes sont bloquées après de 130 km de
la dans la ville de mikolaïve Moscou
affiche toujours sa confiance sur la
réussite des opérations mais sur le plan
humain 7000 soldats russes pourraient
avoir trouvé la mort selon le New York
Times à titre de comparaison 4900
soldats américains étaient décédés lors
de la guerre en Irak qui avait duré 8
ans aucun bilan récent n'a été
communiqué pour leur par la Russie